zu trinken nämlich eine cola essen
schauen wir doch nur leute was auffällt
wir sind die einzigen hier da hinten
sitzen leute also die gehören aber nicht
zu diesem meisterung wir sind die
einzigen die etwas kita-plätze
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja aber
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut so wie
das bis jetzt in dieser ganzen woche
erst ein video kam und ich war die
letzten drei tage echt krank und konnte
absolut für ein video machen ich mag
eigentlich nur im bett waren aber
plötzlich viel besser und ich habe mir
nachts kommt macht einfach mal wieder
ein video und zwar auch mit einem
wirklich coolen inhaltlich nehme das
jetzt gerade im nachlauf also das ganze
video schon fertig ich habe die tage in
kommentar gelesen dass ich doch mal das
am schlechtesten bewertete
restaurantbesuchen soll also mit der
schlechtesten google bewertung das ganze
passiert dir ein stern von 1 bis 5 also
einzelne aspekte fünf das beste ich habe
einst ausgesucht das haben wir heute
zusammen getestet es war wirklich
eigentlich spannend und spannende tag
und ich wünsche euch viel spaß mit dem
video
jetzt kommen wir erst mal zudem
rezension die schauen wir uns minister
genauer an und dann ist auch schon los
viel spaß
ja es dann zur seite bevor es jetzt
losgehen würde ich sagen wir schauen uns
erst mal zusammen die google rezensionen
an
ich habe diese idee unter irgendwie von
mir gelesen ich fand es eigentlich ganz
cool ich habe ja auch schon mal gemacht
das teuerste restaurant in köln obwohl
es im endeffekt gar nicht so teuer war
gut und ich würde sagen wir fangen hier
einfach mal mit dem google rezensionen
an also bei google kommt das ganze
glaube ich auf 2,6 sterne das ist das
schlechteste in ganz köln ich habe extra
lange gesucht hier gibt es dann zum
beispiel kommentare wie unfassbar
unfreundliche bedienung leider nicht
möglich eine portion pommes zu sein wir
zu bekommen nicht die herzliche art die
man gewillt ist sehr schlecht in
unfreundliche bedienung anscheinend darf
man sich da nicht setzen wenn man nicht
essen will obwohl man bekommen eine
obwohl man obwohl man bekommen eines
preis und eine getränkekarte und
schmutzig gute lage unverschämter
service wollten paar kölsch trinken
worauf von einem anmaßend unfreundlichen
kellner aggressiv angepöbelt wurden die
neben stehen restaurants und wesentlich
besser und sie wären zudem wesentlich
markanteres essen also hier muss man
ganz klar sagen wir haben eine
gespaltene meinung es gibt leute die
sind wirklich sehr zufrieden geben fünf
sterne aber wirklich viele geben einfach
nur einen stern so wenn ich denn jetzt
hier aber auf die seite tripadvisor gehe
das ist ja so eine
keine ahnung da sind eigentlich alle
restaurants hotels und so weiter ja
eingezeichnet mit bewertungen da kommt
das ganze gerade so über zwei sterne mit
85 bewertungen und die meisten und halt
wirklich ungenügend und das muss man
erst mal hinkriegen der kellner war
einfach nur frech und dreist hat falsche
gerichte gebracht und meinte es wäre
alles richtig wir würden nicht wissen
was wir bestellt haben null einsicht und
keinen eigenen auf anregung des kunden
in diesem laden kommen wir nie wieder
ja das ist natürlich immer das
wichtigste ich meine ich gehe auch sehr
viel essen weil ich einfach nicht kochen
kann und sobald man ausgezogen das vom
zuhause bleibt mir meistens halten nicht
wirklich was anderes übrig ist natürlich
auch ein gewisser luxus nenne ich jetzt
einfach mal in denen man halt dann
irgendwie reinrutscht und hier in köln
kann ich mich sehr gut aus was gutes
essen angeht und ich bin auch wirklich
schon verwöhnt das kann man ganz offen
ehrlich zu sagen deswegen bin ich jetzt
einfach mal gespannt ich habe einen
kollegen von mir geschrieben dass da mal
hingehen wir haben heute sonntag ich
hoffe das hat auf und ja ich habe hunger
ich habe noch nichts gegessen wird sagen
wir machen uns auf in die kölner
innenstadt und besuchen mal das
restaurant
ich habe keine ahnung ob ich es nennen
darf ich mache erst mal nicht das ganze
für mich natürlich ein bisschen mit
versteckter kamera ihr könnt mir gerne
über instagram weitere restaurants die
absolut grausam sind oder irgendwie
total schlechte bewertung haben zukommen
lassen die ich dann vielleicht auch mal
testen einen hocker platz nach oben da
und wir machen uns jetzt auf den weg
na dann mal los
gib alles na ja immerhin sind die 42 km
gelaufen seit 10 uhr glaubte oder so
echt krass also respekt würde ich nicht
schaffen ich meine wir haben jetzt schon
ungefähr halb 16 uhr also ein 45 16 uhr
fünfeinhalb stunden also müssen wir
jetzt noch ein kilometer geradeaus gehen
wir gehen das ganze zu fuß und ich hoffe
du hast hunger mitgebracht ich bin
richtig sogar aber es gibt also da gibt
es auf jeden fall eine große auswahl von
mediterrane speisen manchmal ist ja
keine ahnung aber da gibt es schnitzel
ist in bergheim eine pizza kann man
direkt sagt ist die gruppe der nicht ja
und nur pizza ist aber auch nicht schwer
sonst gehen wir dann nachher wird auch
hierzu bürger gegen das auch das so ja
auch eine geheime adresse sein so wir
könnten natürlich auch hinter uns ins
hard rock café gehen
leider geht es euch nicht in werkstatt
also da wissen wir auf jeden fall dass
es lecker ist das ding ist ich glaube
das essen da wo wir singen ist auch
nicht schlecht die haben sich nur alle
über die kellner beschwert dass die
kellner alle richtig unfreundlich sind
und sich so raus schicken wenn du nichts
ist dann sagen die mühe das ist nix
hierfür nix essen ich bestelle essen du
sagst du ich trinke erstmal nur okay ich
sage ich will nicht gar nicht erst mal
und dann doch was also ich habe jetzt
mal aushändige switched das ist wirklich
dahin und wo wirklich gute sachen sind
also ich sag mal gute kölner essen kann
man ja so sagen das ist nicht dass wir
noch auffallen hier mit der kamera das
wollen wir ja nicht mehr das direkt am
rhein
wir wissen dass wir doch ganz nett oder
eigentlich sieht schön aus japan kommen
wie lange es dauert es angenommen wird
freute sich weise karte dies eine
ziemlich war hier gibt's grillplatte
lampen was macht so ein leckeres ich
habe auf jeden fall nichts fleischiges
täschchen zurück vielleicht also günstig
ist auf jeden fall gut obwohl das ist
okay vom preis her zu trinken jung in
dem nicola essen schauen unternehmen zu
trinken es breit und habe der
vegetarische sachen und ist auch so hat
der film soll aber jacke dunkler der
publisher zucchini dann einmal also hab
ich schon mal gucken ob wir haben nur
eine sache die vegetarisches aber der
war doch eigentlich ganz nett oder
da waren aber einfach nur eine nacht ist
also für vegetarier ist das hier auf
jeden fall nicht also leute ich nehme
auf jeden fall einem steak von
jakobowski für 16 euro 90 seiten 16 99
für den samstag ist okay ich bekomme
immer ein kleines steak medium genau
ich würde erstmal nichts nehmen ok also
weggeschickt wird er jetzt nicht aber
eigentlich verhindert der typ ist
richtig also leute sedo hat jetzt eine
gemüse butter bestellt also nachhinein
noch werden nur betastet ob das mädchen
dann hat er nicht jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt aufs essen
alexei der restauranttester leute für
noch einen part bei einer restaurant
like-button spreng und die glocke aktive
leute was auffällt wir sind die einzigen
hier da hinten sitzen leute also die
gehören aber nicht zu diesem besserung
wir sind die einzigen einem sonntag und
das ist köln marathon das ist nicht so
gut würde ich mal sagen jetzt sogar hier
als vorspeise ich glaube sogar gratis
rot gekriegt und drei tipps das sieht
bisschen komisch oder lieben ganz normal
dass du ja probieren gab schon probiert
da debatte weil sie das richtig aus aber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gut richtig gekommen also ich finde es
gut aussieht und wie seil aus school das
also so gutes essen vom außenamt ich
schon lange nicht mehr
das ist auch wirklich nicht schlecht 200
haben das ordentliche zwar schon ein
dickes ding com ein geschmack swisscom
erwartet werden wir ja auch mal ein
wörtchen dann gibt es noch probleme mit
der sauce habe ich gehört
wir hatten hier leider keine
kräuterbutter das war auch nicht so
schlimm leute wir sind jetzt fertig das
ist hinter uns
das war echt gut es war vielleicht mal
also man muss ganz ehrlich sagen 2,5
sterne sind viel zu wenig ich schreibe
euch erst mal viereinhalb gibt's den
fünften gibt sich wegen der
kräuterbutter die sie leider nicht haben
und die musst du nimmst dazu aber es war
nicht das schlechteste brauchen ultra
ultra der war so in italienische wurzeln
aber alle zehn minuten
wollen wir das soweit ich werde auf
jeden fall wieder zurück ich habe gerade
auch schon das video so weit geschnitten
jetzt muss ich nur noch das ende auf dem
eigentlich also wir haben jetzt man muss
sagen die lage war echt gut das war
direkt am rhein also das ist hier in
köln so eigentlich der hotspot für ein
gutes restaurant oder für venturi
restaurant wie viele touristen und so
weiter ich habe jetzt insgesamt für zwei
personen 34 eur 50 bezahlen darunter hat
auch einen samstag wir hatten insgesamt
drei getränke das brot und so wird nicht
berechnet wir haben auch noch mal extra
tipps bekommen und so also wirklich
alles richtig cool andere restaurants
also ich habe schon oft miterlebt die
bringen dir einfach brot und schreiben
das dann auf die rechnungen also 34 eur
50 in einem guten restaurant beschweren
kann man sich da auf jeden fall eher
weniger und ich muss ganz offen und
ehrlich sagen ich finde es echt traurig
dass so was halt wirklich in ganz köln
am schlechtesten bewertet ist deswegen
ich habe ja gerade eben schon gesagt ich
schreibe ich jetzt mal kurz eine
einigermaßen positive bewertungen auf
jeden fall genau jetzt kann man es ja
auch ich sagen wir waren im hacienda
hier hat es wie gesagt 2,8 sterben sogar
ok und bei tripadvisor nur 2,4 oder so
aber halt überwiegend schlechte
bewertungen ich weiß nicht woran das
liegt vielleicht liegt es an einem
kellner der nicht immer so den besten
job machst oder halt nach anderen
kellnerin unser kellner war auf jeden
fall super da die schon gesagt ersten
mal auch super ich gebe vier anhalt geht
garnicht viereinhalb sterne geht gar
nicht deswegen gebe ich 54 runden
autokenner war supernett essen lecker
auf wunsch wurde eingegangen gerne
wieder
ich finde das kann man einfach mal
schnell machen weil ist nun ein gutes
restaurant und nur deswegen weil jetzt
schlechte bewertungen auf google da sind
irgendwie kunden abzuschrecken finde ich
sehr schade also da kann man auf jeden
fall mal hingehen weil es das jetzt
irgendwie von dem team sieht schöne
grüße ich hoffe das war okay dass wir
euch so ein bisschen unter die lupe
genommen haben genau falls ihr sowas
nochmal machen soll dass auf jeden fall
in fetten daumen nach oben da hab ich ja
schon gesagt schreib mir gern restaurant
bei instyle wenn man da so wo man mal
hingehen kann vielleicht was dann auch
wirklich schlecht ist stelle ich mir
halt auch extrem lustig war wirklich
sind richtig und freundliche kellner
kommt lasst es mich wissen und wir sehen
uns morgen eventuell wieder sonst
übermorgen haut rein